David Shands of the social proof podcast
we're talking about uncommon ways to
make money in the Creator economy your
entrepreneur story is crazy and we're
going to get into that uh in just a bit
but I kind of want to start off with
just massive value number one uh you
have a YouTube channel you make money
with YouTube ads how's that going
uh it's up and down is really going down
until I went to grow a video your
conference so Implement that stuff and
it it's going back up so yeah
it's amazing how many views a month you
guys get
um a few hundred thousand I really look
at the revenue yeah first off
um like right now we're at about 16
000 15 16 000 and you post video
podcasts what else any Clips or just
video podcast Clips we drop something
every day so video podcast Clips Seven
uploads a week yeah okay yeah and uh no
brand deals or anything on your YouTube
videos all ad Revenue
some people might say well they might
have I don't know let's just say for
instance they have a a t-shirt brand
they'll say hey I want you to shoot an
ad in this particular video this
person's video so I'll charge for that
you know what I mean but uh specific
brand deals so that's number two because
brand deals on your podcast through like
a third-party service is another Revenue
stream yes that's different so YouTube
and podcasts it's like two totally
different ads how does people hit you up
for the T-shirt thing oh they just hit
me so they email you and you're like one
off or they you get they get an ad spot
in a couple of videos yeah I um I try
not to sell one I try to encourage
people not to do one-off yeah and they
might think I'm just trying to upsell
them for five episodes but you really
gotta be in people's face you need to be
like attached to the show Kinda Yeah for
it to be effective for you so um but
yeah if they want one that's fine I'll
just sit there read it put it in the
episode okay so then audio podcast which
is your main thing I think like in the
last 12 months you've had seven million
downloads and uh of course you didn't
start there but uh you got some major
momentum going and so you work uh what
kind of brand deals are coming in how
many episodes have them
um all of them see the thing is not like
you put it in an episode so typically
what they'll do is they'll buy a certain
amount of downloads they'll say well we
can dynamically insert into 80 000
downloads and it's 25 per CPM so for
every thousand you get 25 that's kind of
how the pricing model works but it's
really really cool because once that
once that campaign is done we pull it
out of the episode so what software do
you use for dynamic ads I'll use red
circle that's cool so we use Buzz Sprout
we haven't even started Dynamic but that
means we could go back to our back
catalog as well and insert ads they
always play at the beginning or they can
play anywhere you could do beginning
mid-roll it's just like YouTube where
you put it in the time marker yeah
wherever you want it you put it in there
so it works really well for people who
have something coming up I can say hey
guys this Thursday this thing is coming
up for this particular company and it's
a lot more effective than I would say
even Facebook ads and you could promote
it for that time being and take it out I
think a lot of people don't know about
the power of that that's definitely an
uncommon way to think and a whole nother
reason why building up a library
valuable content on a podcast a video
podcast is so powerful because it's not
just maybe what you did in that episode
but the fact you can go back if you're
getting that Compound Effect and you
just shared your your almost to a
million views a month right now so you
can just kind of keep selling that
inventory because your back catalog is
burning and churning out views listens
downloads absolutely okay that's like
the power of podcasting because we drop
we drop something every day but it's
like full episodes let's say you just
like me interviewing people
well you're going to go back like every
ever it's almost like every video gets a
view every day yeah every day of my life
every video that's every audio yeah
that's cool it's wild how many years
you've been doing it
since uh four years four years four
years yeah so even think media podcast
is only two years old and we did not
start from zero uh we already had a
whole big Channel but like uh my friend
Carrie knew off uh it was like eight or
nine years podcasting so it also it
takes time to get but but it's worth if
you have the vision for like where it's
going so we have YouTube ads brand deals
the third thing is your paid Community
the morning Meetup yes what's that so
the morning Meetup is an organization of
people from all across the world that
jump on a zoom call at eight o'clock
Eastern Standard Time every single day
Monday through Friday so we'll have a
theme for the month like this theme is
winning in the fourth quarter so every
day Monday through Friday the topic of
that day is going to support the theme
for the month so we did one month where
it was called um uh The Millionaire Mind
or whatever yeah every day at another
millionaire talking about whatever it is
that they talk about how they built
their business how they made their
millions or whatever so every day
supports the theme of the month so about
21 days a month or something not weeks
yeah 22 days a month and that's a paid
Community yes 79 a month or 3.99 a year
okay and so people can come and go but
you're building up momentum in there as
well and you can promote that community
in your podcast or everywhere else for
sure word of mouth in the podcast I'll
promote the community the community I
promote watching the podcast yeah so
yeah yeah beautiful okay so we got uh
YouTube ads brand deals paid Community
now you also have a challenge marketing
agency you don't talk about this a lot
we were talking about it before because
again unique ways and and because of
your expertise and some business
partners or collaborators of yours you
work with Niche individuals if it's
going to be a win-win and they want to
to do a challenge you you work with them
and they work on rev share like how does
how many of those do you do a month and
what is that you call it something I
don't know if it's a month I got a
couple really cool Partnerships and if I
see somebody and I believe like for
instance let's say you were going to do
a challenge yeah I truly believe in this
Creator economy I know you need to be
put in front of more people yeah I know
that you're gonna like really take care
of people and give them value I'd say yo
Let's do let's do a challenge together
you you are the Highlight we'll do a
bunch of lives together we'll do some
YouTube lives together you'll jump on
the morning meet up I'll be promoting
you for that time period while we're
doing the live and you know there's a I
mean why we're doing the challenge it's
a very Dynamic you may even pitch
someone who they could be like maybe an
author speaker they already have and
you're like hey what if we also did this
correct and then so there's a lot of
ways it could come about but only a
couple times a year yeah only a couple
and only I really have to like the
person yeah I don't like doing shout out
to tarika like we literally in our
Mastermind there's hundreds of people in
our Mastermind now she didn't to do it
she got five six hundred units of real
estate so she's like she understands
that space and she didn't do Social
Media stuff like that yeah and uh it's
been a beautiful partnership I think
like 60 70 or Mastermind actually has
real estate it's just phenomenal so that
was an amazing partnership and we have a
real we have a relationship like that's
my girl you know what I mean so
are you ready to start or grow your
YouTube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots join this
free web class where you'll learn the
step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
number five is workshops yeah for sure
and so and I'm tomorrow at the time of
recording I'm about to train at the
podcast there's boot cancer uh how many
workshops you do a year
um I do maybe four or five a year yeah
now that I have this space I'll probably
do one a month yeah yeah okay so and uh
and you could charge uh admission it
just went off you got tickets for that
100 and what are they either charge
admission
if it's like for this one is very
specific I'll charge admission sometimes
I'll charge admission but the people in
my morning meet up just get to come for
free as a perk yeah it's just because
virtually did you stream it too
sometimes so are do you have local
people in the morning meet up or they
can fly in it's local but I'll go to
different cities because I can see we
got like about a thousand people in it
yeah and I can see where a good
concentration of people are so like in
Florida they're doing they do their own
Meetup from the Meetup like they just
get together in their community so I
flew down there a little while ago and
just hung out with them for a day coach
trained flew right back and do that
around the city what other topics on the
uh boot camp I mean other boot camps is
it always podcasting or do you do other
ones I did a Content creation boot camp
which was more General like tomorrow is
just more focused on podcasting uh me
and my me and my partner my co-host
Donnie we did a bland brand Clarity boot
camp so whatever I think that people can
be serviced with we do it yeah okay and
then the the final one and there might
be others but these are big ones for you
is uh is a podcast video Studio a brand
new podcast video Studio that's you
launched for yourself and your team but
also that you can rent out Studios we're
recording in one of them right now we're
here in North Atlanta so you got a
physical space almost 4 000 square feet
and I'm inspired by this because this
speaks to
um uh taking revenue from what you've
done before taking the momentum taking
the vision and then compounding that
even into the next thing so what's kind
of like your vision in a nutshell on the
part two of this podcast we're going to
kind of unpack your story and talk about
uh the Creator's Clubhouse the podcast
Studio but what's like the nutshell
vision of of how this even came about
well it's interesting I I'm just looking
at the numbers
and I wanted my own Studio I wanted to
have it like build out my studio we have
we have an event space where I was doing
a studio where you had like breakdown
and like setup and all that kind of
stuff and I was like I wanted a space
where I can record my own but also a
plug and play podcasting Studio that was
like the original Vision because I just
see this podcasting thing coming but
people don't know how to do it right so
if we have a space and I can like teach
them how to record their own podcast I
don't got to worry about it you rent the
room call it a day
um but the model like evolves because I
literally didn't have a I didn't have a
solid model when I bought the building I
just knew I needed a building yeah I
mean like if you're going to own a space
in terms of like you're SP if you're
going to be the best stylist in the
world right you need to buy a salon yeah
you need to have a Decked Out Salon if
you're going to be I don't know a you
know a sneaker kind of store you need to
buy a Snicker store so I just say if I'm
gonna like own this space and I'm gonna
be the teacher of it I want to have more
social proof than anybody
a lot of people can start a podcast but
not everybody's going to be able to
start a podcast and then teach a podcast
and get people results some people can
start a podcast and teach a podcast but
not everybody's gonna have a podcasting
Studio where you can facilitate podcasts
so I'm just continuing to I just got to
keep separating myself from the other
people in the industry it's beautiful
um so David uh thank you so much you're
on social at sleep is for suckers with
the number four social proof podcast
just go to your Apple or Spotify device
and download social proof podcast is an
experience we drop something every
single day we will feed you every single
day on social podcast uh social proof
YouTube channel or everywhere yes yes
and uh definitely check out part two of
this podcast we're gonna unpack the
vision that's super inspiring about
creators Clubhouse uh some of the
details behind that and how maybe you
could Envision doing something bigger in
your city even if you're you know
starting small we're thinking big in
small places We're Dreaming big and
we're planning for the next season one
more income Revenue stream oh yeah bonus
income Revenue stream here we are let's
go so we have a podcast Mastermind that
uh I don't know if I'll do it again but
um I was teaching the podcasters that
you need to learn podcasting and learn
what camera to use and microphones and
all that kind of stuff because one major
Revenue source is being a content
creator for people at businesses so if I
have a business
I probably right now I probably have
thought of a podcast you know what I
mean like everybody they're thinking oh
I need to start a podcast to do this but
people don't really know what type of
camera to use how you're going to shoot
it all at but if you learn it you can be
a content creator for digital marketers
so you say yo every single uh you know
once a week will come together shoot
your podcast we'll clip it up edit it
only because I know how to do it now I
can sell that as a service for you also
corporations are starting their own
podcast so I have a um it's an
organization out in La who they have
they're built they're building out the
podcast arm of their business and
because I understand podcasting they
contracted me to be the person to help
them build it out you know what I mean
so the skill set of learning what we all
can see coming everybody wants to start
a podcast
if you learn how to do the thing
everybody wants to get in get started
you can facilitate it for them or
somebody might not want a podcast but
you need to know how to set up a camera
and mic for these digital marketers
saying yeah let's go shoot your ads for
this week yeah pay you for this thing
yeah yeah so so being either freelance
or starting your own small business to
serve business owners and corporations
especially with 5x growth just this year
in the crater economy with everybody
wanting to get into this you're
investing in a wave that's not coming
it's already here and it's definitely
time to ride that way it's like the
people who learned computers before it
was like popping yeah I mean like oh I
can I can code something and you're like
what is code nobody knows what it means
be the person who can facilitate that
just get for get you're you're early
right now to the Mark I know everybody
is a content creator and it seems
saturated we got a lot of years left in
this thing really
foreign